um irgendwelche getränk gegeben und her
transportieren zu können wir auf den
sack zu gehen ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung hatte was geht ab netz bekommen
bei einem neuen video immer wieder auf
einem kanal und so ja ich denke ihr
solltet alle wissen dass zurzeit ja die
fußball-wm ist und habe ihr geraten
guckt das ist jetzt irgendwie halb eins
oder so ich habe bock auf dem video und
deswegen mache ich das jetzt auch für
euch und zwar geht es heute um die top
fünf dinge die mich am meisten an der
weltmeisterschaft aufregen es gibt
wirklich extrem viel was wir so
aufgefallen ist und habe ich mir gedacht
komm passte darüber einfach mal ein
video deswegen viel spaß damit und haut
rein und dann würde ich sagen wir fangen
anderen punkt nummer eins und zwar war
glaube ich schon in südafrika oder war
es halt nur mit diesem wohl sela kacke
die dann irgendwann auch rausgefiltert
wurde auf jeden fall
ich sitze manchmal guckt fußball und
dann denke ich einfach mal so die
zuschauer im stadion kommt die
gegnerische mannschaft hat jetzt sind
wir keine runde
also ich sitze auf dem sofa und dann
kommt er aus dem fernseher dieses
gepfeife und von hinten kommt das
irgendwie auch durch irgend so eine box
oder so ein ja das ist dann irgendwie
auch so abwechseln wenn die eine
mannschaft den ball greifen die einfällt
und wenn die anderen mannschaften bald
die anderen fans und weiß nicht das geht
echt übel so froren und das regt mich so
auf wie weiß nicht ob man das irgendwie
herausstellen kann oder so aber ich habe
bis jetzt leider noch keinen weg
gefunden so dann komme es auch schon zu
punkt 2 und ich würde mal sagen kenne
das auch alle dieses public viewing halt
nur ganz viele menschen auf einem fleck
sind und dann fußball gucken und da bin
ich halt auch ganz gerne
aber da gibt es auch so ein zwei sachen
die mir vor augen sagt ihnen da
verstehen die leute nicht man stellt
sich damit ein rein und will halt gucken
und andauernd kommt irgendwie von der
seite könnte ich mal durchgehen oder
dann kommt der danebenstand kann ich mir
dadurch kommt eine minute später wenn
wir stellen sich daneben und fragt fünf
minuten später wieder könne nicht ruhig
gehen es gibt leute die kommen dann
dahin und die sind dann echt tolle spiel
irgendwie irgendwo unterwegs um
irgendwelche
bringt gehen und her transportieren zu
können irgendwie auf den sack zu gehen
ich weiß nicht keine ahnung was mich
doch auch als dritten punkt extrem an
kurz sind es passiert die auf was bei
der wm ja ist ja klar da passiert da mal
faul und da mal irgendwas aber wenn ich
dort mal auf facebook unterwegs findet
die medien die machen aus sondern klein
wie nennt man das auslacht kleinen lücke
die nur oder sony liefert zum beispiel
du hast im spiel geguckt und da ist
irgendwas passiert und dann bist du auf
facebook unterwegs und dann liest du das
oder die szene die die medien auch meine
denken lieber ist mit euch falsch davon
ist 10.10 erfunden
10 10 19 würde ich mal sagen neun
zehntel
es ist schon spät ich bin müde aber ich
mache trotzdem ein video
tja und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon
bei punkt 24 das jetzt zwar auch von
anderen spielen aber es ist bei dieser
wm auch extrem so ich meinen luchsen
spielen und es liegt wirklich alle drei
minuten irgendwie auf dem boden und
wälzt sich da hin und her waren berührt
wurde von seinem gegenspieler das ist so
krass ich meine du wirst man sieht
richtig der mittlere kleines bisschen
berühmter welche sich dann kommt noch
diese männer mit diesem komischen
orangen dingen was im tage sein soll
transportieren in der deckung der welt
sich dann auch noch mal fünf frei hin
und her verstehen warum warum macht man
so was sie können einfach vernünftig
fußball spielen dann sind auch zuschauer
zufrieden die anleihen kommen jetzt auch
schon zum letzten punkt und zwar das
auch schon ziemlich viele andere
youtuber gesagt aber ich will es auch
noch mal so ein bisschen auf den punkt
bringen und zwar erst mal vorbei ich
guck sehr gerne fußball ich guck
logischerweise noch gerne die
weltmeisterschaft aber ich würde
wirklich noch mal viel lieber gucken
wenn ich wissen würde ja die ist in
england oder ein vielleicht auch amerika
wo wirklich sonne wm platziert werden
könne sei ich mal nicht brasilien wo
heute die fifa komplett alles voll
gefüllt hatten irgendwelchen stalin
anstatt das geld einmal kommen ihr
kriegt jetzt mal ein paar schulen oder
so ja das habe ich echt nicht verstanden
warum das muss man doch auch einschätzen
können als fifa dass das keinen sinn
ergibt oder dass das echt scheiße ist
kann ich zwar nicht viel gegen machen
aber ich wollte halt auch euch nochmal
sagen dass es mich auch extrem ankommt
und dass ich das auch überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann
und ja ich denke oder ich hoffe euch
jeder genauso ja leute das war's dann
leider schon wieder an mit diesem video
aber bitte jetzt kurz noch nicht
wegschalten muss er nämlich noch sagen
es war es so ich weiß nicht wie das
video später bei euch ankommt das war
meine meinung ich denke ihr habt alle
eine andere meinung zu diesen ganzen
sachen die da passieren ich weiß auch
nicht ob das so um eine zielgruppe
zutrifft dieses thema jetzt speziell ich
wollte einer machen weil ich bock drauf
hatte
und weil ich halt total gerne
weltmeisterschaft gucke ansonsten hoffe
ich natürlich erst hat euch gefallen
weil es der fall es gibt da einfach mal
daumen nach oben schwätzen kommentar
oder so ansonsten abonnieren nicht
vergessen wir sind bald schon 9000 oder
so keine haare auf jeden fall richtig
geil und in der beschreibung instagram
und co hier auf der linken seite geht's
weiter mit meinem letzten video das war
so ein tag und hier auf der rechten
seite fünf arten von fans auch ganz
witzig gewonnen check auf jeden fall
beides macht würd mich freuen und wir
sehen uns dann im laufe nächster woche
wieder v3